why are doing this to me well this is
one of the best videos to hit the
internet I'm gonna swipe right on either
Selva lizzo choosing which celebs she'd
swipe right on you know like on a dating
app and let me tell you the choices are
hard I'm gonna swipe right on old oh I'm
gonna swipe left on Justin Bieber but
clearly lizzo knows what's up when it
comes to the BTS army listen I'm not
trying to get cancelled I'm swiping
right on BTS I mean easy obvious choice
some choices we're not so easy though
that's so hard
how much wipe right on TLC and sorry
Kris Jenner
The Smiths I'm Swiper right and while
she didn't swipe right over left on
Justin Timberlake she still sang his
praises oh my god I didn't even really
smell Justin Timberlake like that but
you didn't think he was recently with
Liz oh where she also gushed about JT we
had a lot of fun we laughed a lot he's
got great energy and so do I so um
whatever we do will be made from love
and made from fun he gets okay he goes
crazy like he was like like he is his
world you know we're all kind of living
it as well as other celebs like Rihanna
I know Rihanna's a big fan of yours girl
would and I wanna know when there's a
collaboration listen we need a video of
Rihanna in the studio period we don't
know what where is the music Rihanna I'm
not gonna bother cuz I know what that
feels like hell so I'm gonna let her do
what she ought to do and how's this for
amazing
Rihanna just responded to that 2et
she wants to collab with Liz oh praise
be
I will collaborate with her on the
lights for this interview right now
Liz Goa is so badass and she's
everything the savage dance for ya a
confident woman
no matter what size color shape your
attitude is what makes you savage yeah
it's the confidence that you have in
yourself and it's the confidence that
you can give off to people so when is
this club happening unfortunately maybe
not for a while cuz Rihanna also said
this asking about my album I just knew
it
well obviously I'm a confident woman so
whatever I do it's gonna copping out
whether it's the album perfume lingerie
um makeup or fashion y'all gonna have to
wait maybe I'm so sorry
anyways that's it for today for all the
latest on Liz oh and your other favorite
celebs keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now